[Music]
cathedral is with us hey khadira how are
you
hi i'm well thank you for having me sure
what's up in your world
so i have a significant amount of
student loan debt it's around sixty
seven thousand
i also have
around nineteen thousand twenty thousand
in a personal loan repayment as well as
about five thousand in credit card debt
i just received a 20 000
bonus from my job and i want to know
what makes the most sense do i apply it
to
the
student loan or do i pay off the
personal loan what makes the most sense
for me that's a good question thank you
for being a listener we appreciate it
and a new listener at that
so um here's what we teach and then the
more important thing is why we teach it
all right we want you to get out of debt
as fast as you possibly can and
apparently you're moving that direction
since you gave me all your debts and
then said i've got some money
um and the reason we want you to get out
of debt as fast as you possibly can is
that frees up your most powerful wealth
building tool which is your income
okay so we're in agreement we want to
get out of that the fastest possible way
we also want to get out of debt in a way
that causes us to actually finish the
plan so
this only works
this suggestion of mine the answer to
your question only works if it's if it's
not the only thing you do but it's part
of the whole thing that you do as you
plug into this whole ramsey ecosystem on
money okay so within that ecosystem
you're going to live like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else you're going to sell so much
stuff the kids think they're next you're
going to live on nothing you're not
going out to eat you're not going on a
vacation you're going to pour every
dollar at this debt with great intensity
and then you're going to get out of debt
okay now if you're gonna do all of that
then this works if you're gonna screw
around with it and ish it
it's not gonna work
so i gotta give you that caveat to the
advice now what we in that context what
we teach people to do is list your debts
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything with the smallest debt and
attack the smallest debt and then the
next and then the next and then the next
that gives you a sense of
traction
a sense of power
a sense of destiny that this is going to
work it gives you hope
and so i'm going to list your 5 000
worth of credit cards and i'm going to
pay them off and then i'm going to pay
the rest of it on the personal loan and
as soon as i get that personal loan
going i don't have any credit card
payments i don't have any personal loans
then i'm going to attack the
student loans with a vengeance because
you're going to pay off all but 5 000 of
the personal loans and you're going to
cut up your stupid credit card so they
didn't grow back
okay just making sense
yes it's making sense
okay there's a lot of recurring payments
that i need to get rid of on my credit
card so that i can do that yeah we'll
just move them over your debit card yeah
or in you know that's what i use i use a
debit card and you got to move them over
but chomp them up
get rid of them and if you take 20 000
and apply it to 20 and 5 then that
leaves only 5 000 on the personal loan
did i do that math right
yeah okay and you make how much 90
no i make 160. oh great okay so you're
gonna knock out that other five in like
20 minutes right
yeah yeah and then we're gonna knock out
the student loans in less than one year
and you're going to be free how long
have you had these student loans
since 2015. okay it's time for sallie
mae to leave your life
seven years is too long for her to be
invading your space
yes
so john the power of paying off the
smallest to largest that incremental
progress that's exactly psychology about
that john has a phd in psychology so i
can ask him about these things yeah so
do you
you're either overwhelmed or the joy is
welling up inside you and you can't
speak which one is it
i'm a little overwhelmed okay i'm a
little nervous so
just to just to reiterate what dave just
said by the end of today you're gonna
have no credit card debt
you're gonna have five grand left on a
family loan that with your income
hopefully you can go to the bank and get
that five grand and you're out of that
one too
and then after today because of one free
phone call and because you're ready to
knock this thing out then you just gotta
tackle the the last big ugly hairy dog
there and move your credit card cut your
credit cards up and get a debit card
right and then you're ready to rock and
roll that's i there's an intensity to
this though and you feel that is that
what's a little overwhelming
yes i absolutely need to be rid of all
of it yeah so here's what we have
discovered and this is for the benefit
of all our listeners but also for you
what we've discovered is personal
finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge
you've been you're a smart lady i can
tell by talking to you just how
articulate you are you've been trying to
fix this with your intellect and it's
not an intellectual problem
it's a i didn't get pissed off at sally
may and i'm kicking the old woman out of
my freaking house
problem
there's an emotion a visceral
move to this
and that is tied to the success of
people who get out of debt
you cannot fix
a problem that you made emotionally with
an intellectual fix you have to fix it
with an emotional change and that
applies to
marital issues that applies to most
mental health issues you can't think
your way out of most of these problems
you can get a plan
cognitively but then you got to go do
you got to go be different you got to
act different right little by little by
little yeah good that's a great call and
that's for you know her call is for all
of you
out there so
here's the deal
they actually did a study at
northwestern university
that uh studied the idea of paying off
your debts highest interest rate first
versus smallest to largest
and the conclusion of this university
study was
dave ramsey's right
and we're like well we kind of already
knew that because we already taught 10
million people how to do this while you
guys were doing that study up there in a
vacuum but um dave i've been at those
tables where we're discussing data and
everyone
kind of hangs their head like oh man we
didn't expect these fun i just imagined
that table they were going to show you
no i i well i don't know i don't know
whether they
if they if they they did at least come
out and publicly
they put it out okay and they literally
did say all this time ramsay's been
right yeah you know so i don't know
whether they were trying to prove me
right or prove me wrong but it doesn't
matter we already knew we were right
because we had more proof social text
than proof texts than they had so we
already knew that we had more data than
they would have ever seen with a number
of people that have actually done this
but that's the thing guys you've got to
have a level of hope and you know your
behaviors your impulse your lack of
control your disorganization your
immaturity your inability to delay
pleasure these are all things that you
got to fix it's called growing up
and when you do and you apply a that a
behavior fix
to getting out of debt you'll get out of
debt but when you try to intellect your
way out of a behavior problem you can't
do it